[Musique]
le cnar mais ses partenaires dresse le
bilan de ce premier semestre de
recrutement depuis le début de l'année
c'est plus de 600 postes qui ont été
pourvus en métropole le comité national
d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité et le premier
facilitateur d'emploi en mobilité sur le
territoire nous mettons en oeuvre des
dispositifs d'accompagnement concret
qu'ils soient humains ou matériels
puisqu'on prend en charge billets
d'avion on prend en charge les deux
premiers mois d'hébergement et cetera
quand vous avez que nous prenons en
charge évidemment la mise en relation
des entreprises pour les entretiens de
recrutement prenons en charge les
préparations mobilité quand nous faisons
tous là bas nous nous sommes j'allais
dire assez performant utile et nous
sommes d'ailleurs unique en son genre et
domiens une centaine de jeunes étaient
présents suite à leur sélection ces deux
dernières semaines
huit entreprises de métropole étaient
venus recruter des réunionnais à 40 ans
vincent salama l'attend laventure de la
mobilité en métropole comme cariste
j'avais blot déjà je me suis mis à la
recherche d'un emploi pour pouvoir
progresser dans la métropole grossier à
mon cv peut-être retourner plus tard à
la retraite
le jeune il est gagnant parce qu'il est
accompagné il est fort mais il est
vraiment bichonné par les équipes d'une
arme le territoire également s'y
retrouve puisque notre taux de chômage
baisse et 2000 départs par an ce n'est
pas rien avec un coût qui est moindre
entre 6000 et 10 mille euros par jeune
c'est vraiment ça défie toute
concurrence et je crois que le
territoire est également gagnant parce
que le jeune il et il se sent plus fort
il est plus ouvert sur le monde
les entreprises sont contents d'avoir
des jeunes qui sont formés et qu'ils
sont plus compétents que le cnps armes
poursuit sa mission d'accompagnement à
l'emploi aux jeunes réunionnais qui
souhaitent partir en métropole ou à
l'étranger chaque année près de 2500
d'entre eux tentent l'aventuré de la
mobilité
[Musique]